the jurgen experience and what's the
story are you moving
i'm out of here when do you leave soon
texas or yeah i'm gonna go to texas
i got a farm in vermont yeah it's a
little cold oh it's cold
i i i just want to go somewhere in the
center of the country
somewhere it's easier to travel to both
places and somewhere we have a little
bit more freedom
also i think that um where we live right
here in los angeles is overcrowded
and i think most of the time that's not
a problem but i think it's exposing the
fact that it's a real issue
when you look at the number of pieces
people that uh
are catching covid because of this
overpopulation
issue when you look at the traffic when
you look at the
economic despair when you look at the
homelessness problem that's accelerated
radically over the last uh six seven ten
years
i think there's too many people here i
think it's not tenable i don't think
it's manageable and i think every mayor
does a [ __ ] job of doing it
because i don't think anybody could do a
great job of it i think there's like
certain things you're going to have to
deal with
when you have a population of whatever
the [ __ ] la is it's like
20 million plus people it's too many
people it's too many people
yeah that's what i think i think where
you're living is probably the perfect
way to do it it's 500 people
that's nuts but then you got those uh
dudes yelling at you where's the deer
where they stand the language i could go
on we could do
hours of the negatives of a small town
oh yeah there's no negatives
everybody knows your business yeah
everybody knows what you're doing
where you're going you know there's pros
and cons to everything
but i think uh i think you have a better
opportunity at more pros
when there's less folks i agree so small
town texas or
let's just leave it at that yeah i got
ideas jamie's coming
nice look at him he's all excited it
doesn't affect the business
no we're just gonna do it from there but
that's the other thing is texas has
comedy they have stand-up comedy i've
been doing i did well i haven't been
doing but i did one weekend in texas
while all this was going on
it was the first weekend i was able to
do stand-up but then my friends were in
san antonio and they got coveted down
there but those knuckleheads were out
there
talking to people and shaking hands and
taking pictures and stuff and
texas would be the last stand place to
ever wear a mask or
not shake a hand they wear masks though
people are wearing masks
last time i was there i think now
they're woken up right well
this is a weird disease man
[Applause]